a decade ago New York mother Lenore scan
Daisy caused a big stir after she wrote
a column explaining why she routinely
let her nine-year-old son ride the
subway alone but her philosophy known as
free range kids launched a movement of
like-minded parents and this week the
state of Utah put some of that thinking
into law making it explicitly legal for
a child to travel or play without
supervision and Lenore's can AZ is here
to talk more about this then we're
welcome well thank you any guys well
tell me a little bit more about this
Utah law the Utah law says parents
shouldn't have to worry if they're going
to send their kids out to play outside
or walk to school that they may be
arrested because we've heard of some
very high-profile cases where that
happened to meet eaves in Maryland
you might remember they let their kids
ten and six walk home from the park in a
neighborhood that was you know they felt
safe in that they've moved there for the
kids and yet they were investigated not
once but twice for letting their kids
have this very basic freedom I mean when
I was a kid my crossing guard was ten
and yet these people were arrested for
letting their ten-year-old walk home to
their own place so nobody wants to have
to second-guess themselves if they want
to let their kids play outside or walk
to school and in Utah they don't have to
worry this all started when you wrote
this column titled why I let my
nine-year-old ride the subway alone it
got you as we mentioned the nickname
America's worst mom really you were you
were just trying to give your kids their
freedom back right well in this case our
younger son had been asking if we would
take him someplace and let him find his
own way home on the subway but I really
you know the reason it caused such a
stir was because I'd let him have any
independence whatsoever and what has
changed since at least we were kids is
that letting your kid out of your sight
is almost considered negligence because
we believe that the world is so teeming
with danger that why would anybody let
their kid do anything on their own and
in fact the world is safer than when we
were kids the crime rate is back to what
it was in 1963 safe if you weren't used
to ride the bus alone at the age of
seven and eight yeah yeah so why
shouldn't that be something that we can
give our kids back and you know I bet
you liked it right it wasn't a horrible
one or here's what I struggle with as a
parent in this day
I don't know what age is appropriate to
let my child do that and I feel like
every child is different right the kid
next door might be okay walking down the
street but I don't know that my son is
well that's true but the thing to
remember is that somehow all kids in the
rest of the world all are walking to
school by age seven so even if your kid
is a little Spacey or you think your kid
is irresponsible if you give them a
little little responsibility they rise
to the occasion and that's why we can't
be second-guessed as parents when we say
my kid is ready to do that so between
free-range kids and now I run something
called let grow which is free range kids
with a budget okay we're just trying to
give that freedom back to the kids
because when you do give it like my kids
if I'm crossing the street with them I
worry that they're just not paying
enough attention but when you're not
with them they have to pay attention
are you expecting other states like Utah
out of laws you are yes because wouldn't
you rather live in a state where if you
decide your kid is ready to play outside
or go to the park without you for on a
Saturday morning like this don't you not
want to get arrested they tried to pass
something like this in Arkansas right
they tried to pass it in Arkansas it
passed in the Senate and then it's it's
stalled in the house because they
started worrying about abduction which
is the rarest crime in America stranger
danger is something that we believe is
rampant it's actually very rare but when
you bring it up it's it's the boogeyman
it's literally the boogeyman and then
that caused them to stop that's why I
got to give credit to Utah it passed
unanimously so this is not a left thing
or a right thing this is people
realizing as a parent I want to be able
to make decisions for my own kid and as
and we not we want kids who are brave
who are solve their problems they can't
solve their problems if we're always
there solving that silverskin AZ thank
you so much for being with us this
morning - appreciate it